le trou des halles pour la sans doute à
un emplacement qui aura intrigué plus
d'un parisien et d'un provincial surtout
depuis qu'a été inaugurée la nouvelle
liaison du rer tenez fait un test
interrogez n'importe lequel les
habitants du quartier pour savoir ce qui
est en train de s'y construire et
personne ne faut fournir à la même
réponse et il est vrai qu'au fur et à
mesure de l'enquète cap conduite pierre
champetier le dossier se révéler des
plus compliquée tant les décisions sur
les halles ont pu évoluer
à deux pas de l'église saint-eustache un
énorme blockhaus haut de six étages
c'est la centrale thermique
un peu plus loin une dizaine de tours l2
5 mètres de hauteur pour l'aération les
ascenseurs et les escaliers de ce clip
telles sont les contraintes techniques
que les ingénieurs du sous-sol ont légué
aux architectes de la surface en sous
sol il y à déjà le rer le métro et
bientôt le forum commercial quarante
mille mètres carrés de magasins galeries
la moitié est déjà lourd
en surface un seul projet avancé celui
de l'architecte espagnol ricardo beau
fils sont ensemble de logements sociaux
doit camoufler la centrale mais le
permis de construire n'a pas encore été
donnée pour l'instant s'il béton et
c'est maintenant quand il faut vraiment
renverser la situation et faire dominer
les architectes et lary soulan semble
donc c'est un gros morceau de giresse
vanille ah oui mais on a tellement des
choses à digérer que c'est pas une se
passer de morceau le plus difficile au
fond on est à côté de cette usine et on
va transformer de notre côté cette usine
alain ruel qu'il va être une monde un
univers différents et même univers
fantastique faut accepter toutes les
morales non écoutez moi je suis
quelqu'un de bien clair et je sais
jusqu'où je peux aller avec les choses
jusque quand je peux écrire quand les
halles pas seul à la barre et ça a plu
une oeuvre d'art moi je partirai où je
serai pas là tant que les halles c'est
encore une possibilité
moi je reste inverse
en face devant la fontaine des innocents
ne sais plus les promoteurs se sont
décommandés il faut repartir de zéro
jusqu'ici un seul permis de construire a
été accordé dans la partie centrale en a
donné le feu vert à la construction d'un
énorme cube de béton de 140 m de long et
2 5 mètres de haut il s'agit de masquer
les tours et d'abriter 6000 m² de
commerces supplémentaires au dessus en
prévoit un auditorium mais on aurait
peut-être pu attendre les plans avant
d'imposer l'architecte pareil sauf qu'il
s'agit que l'architecte pour bâtir son
auditorium il n'aura pas le
rez-de-chaussée le rez-de-chaussée déjà
occupé à autre chose ça arrive qu'on
fasse un bâtiment dont le
rez-de-chaussée sera destiné à quelque
chose et puis au dessus du
rez-de-chaussée à autre chose ce n'est
pas quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est
même la règle générale généralement
quand on fait un bâtiment il ya des
commerces au sous sol et puis des
appartements au dessus c'est le problème
de l'escaut on n'imagine pas beaubourg
avec des commerces au rez de chaussée
quand même pas pourquoi pas auriez-vous
dans les commerces de la réponse centre
beaubourg ou pas du tout je reviendrai
pas du tout vous savez on voit tellement
tueur dans beaubourg ça m'aurait pas
gêné du tout
et le jardin on vient d'en changer le
dessin le projet beau fils avec ses
pièces d'eau et ses colonnades est
battue en brèche par le projet de la
société d'aménagement des halles des
allées d'arbres une pelouse centrale
d'admiration c'est un jardin classique
auquel quelques tours de sécurité
déguisé en fabrique donneront une petite
touche romantique
en
ces changements ces retards c'est
incertitude s'explique par la difficulté
d'adapter les orientations
présidentielles à l'ancien plan
d'aménagement déjà mise en train
songez que la plus grande promenade du
monde la plus belle la plus grande
promenade du monde peut être aménagée de
la place du palais royal parce que la
place des vosges via les allées beaucoup
la conclusion c'est que on est enfin une
vue ambitieuse n'ont pas une vue étroite
de l'urbanisme de paris et que l'on
songe à aménager ici
un parcours
pour le bonheur des habitants des
enfants des plus vieux les plus jeunes
et que les halles soit l'un des points
parmi les autres d'un immense parcours
où les gens enfin retrouverait le
plaisir de l'échangé de la rencontre et
non pas comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
un aménagement principalement tournée
vers la vente de produits de luxe
les halles était autrefois un lieu de
rencontre
elles furent aussi un lieu
d'affrontement
après 15 ans d'études et de projets en
ignore encore ce qu'elles seront demain
oh